good evening california's democratic
governor gavin newsom handily shut down
a recall effort tuesday he will serve
out the rest of his term despite a
republican push to oust him from the
leadership of the nation's most populous
state i'm humbled
and grateful to the millions and
millions of californians that exercise
their fundamental right
to vote
and express themselves so overwhelmingly
by rejecting the division
by rejecting the cynicism by rejecting
so much of the negativity that's defined
our politics
while some voters chose to line up and
cast their ballots in person every
registered eligible voter received a
ballot in the mail beginning weeks ago
the overriding issue has been newsom's
handling of the coronavirus pandemic he
was among the first governors to declare
widespread lockdowns and mask mandates
that angered many business owners and
others who joined anti-massacres and
republicans to support the recall more
than 40 candidates were on the ballot to
replace newsome but the leading
republican was larry elder a
conservative radio talk show host who
promised to lift all coveted masks and
vaccination mandates elders spoke after
his defeat
as you know
my opponent governor gavin newsom
come on
let's
let's let's be gracious let's be
gracious in defeat
and by the way
we may have lost
the
battle but we are going to win the war
[Applause]
newsom attacked elder relentlessly over
his stance on covid he spent 70 million
dollars on tv ads and campaign stops
around the state and he had help from
prominent democrats including president
joe biden that message resonated with
voters
if we recall governor newsom who knows
who we end up with and the options in my
opinion are not looking very good elder
was endorsed by former president donald
trump but in this heavily democratic
state trump's support may have done
elder more harm than good it's likely
that democrats from the white house to
state houses all around the country are
breathing a sigh of relief and
republicans are disappointed by the
failure of their effort to turn the
golden state red
rob reynolds al jazeera beverly hills
california